-Hi, buddy, how are you?
-How are you?
-You know, you're now
our most frequent guest.
-I was told
I pulled into the lead today.
-Congratulations.
-Pretty --
I'm feeling pretty good
about it.
-Big deal. Big day to do it.
-I just called my guy
who edits my Wikipedia page.
-You have a guy?
-No.
-I got to get a guy to do that.
-By the way,
you may just want to --
-You -- I think
leading up to today,
there were, rightfully so,
fears about safety,
fears about the many
COVID protocols
that would have to take place,
and that maybe clouded
what today could be.
And now that its happened
and we've seen the inauguration,
did you find optimism in it?
-A lot, yeah. I feel --
You know, the thing
I said last night was
my feeling has been like
if you've ever been
in a near-miss car accident,
that feeling afterwards of,
like, adrenaline and excitement.
It's not joy. It's not like --
You're like, "Wow,
I came real close just there."
-Well, especially when you think
about the numerous negatives
this president had
in the minds of voters,
it was so close.
-Right. Yes.
-Like it wasn't in the end,
you know, again,
as a pure numerical vote count,
it was a repudiation,
but the electoral college
did not repudiate Donald Trump.
-No, I mean, it was --
Again, the whole wiring
of the system is faulty.
I think that's clear, you know?
So, I think my --
I definitely felt real relief
and some joy today,
some real hope
about what we avoided
and how bad it could have been
and what we have,
through a lot of effort
by our fellow Americans
of all different kinds
of walks of life --
I mean, you know,
we have this thing, right,
where we think about
these, like,
you know,
there's the Rust Belt diners,
and then, there's the, like,
effete urban college grads
or whatever.
It's a big country,
and there were people
who were going
to Black Lives Matter protests
in small towns in the Midwest,
and there were people who were
doing women's marches in Idaho.
And there's all kinds of people
from all kinds
of different backgrounds
who came together to say
this is not right.
And they did it for four years
and, in the end,
saved the country
from what I think
would have been essentially
its last chapter as the
democracy that it used to be.
-I am thinking, you know,
it's not quite a parallel,
but you know, obviously,
one of the things
that President Biden
had to address today
is the fact that we have
this COVID crisis --
that, you know, I think
due to real exhaustion
with the numbers,
with the attention
on both the election
and the aftermath
of the election --
And you have done a great job
of drawing attention to the fact
that we have just sort of
normalized this terrible crisis
with this growing death toll.
And much like -- You know,
the Obama/Biden administration
obviously came in in the middle
of the financial crisis,
but part of
when you think about the fact
that Donald Trump complained
about inauguration size,
like, there really
wasn't as much going on
insofar as, like,
a crisis to this magnitude.
-Yeah, I mean, again,
you keep searching
for, like, the right analog
or precedent,
and there is nothing great.
I mean, you know,
it was striking to me --
You know, it is part
of our kind of civic sacraments
that we talk about Lincoln.
-Yeah.
-Because Lincoln, is, you know,
he is the sort of "sartemic"
figure, rightly so.
But today, it had -- Like,
when we talk about the union,
disunion, and uncivil war,
when you quote Lincoln,
you know,
Lincoln took over a nation
gripped in what would be its
probably worst crisis ever --
And FDR was close.
And I remember
being on the steps in 2009
when we were losing
800,000 jobs a month
and looked like the whole thing
could go under.
This is even worse than that.
And I thought that --
I think that Biden has done
a very good job,
I think the whole
incoming administration
has done a very good job
of centering COVID.
I mean, one of
the weirdest things,
surreal and sadistic
in its own way,
was that
because of the narcissism
and sociopathic
kind of proclivities
of the last president, talking
about people dying from COVID
was viewed by him
and his faction
as an insult to him personally.
It was --
You couldn't talk about it,
because you were then
insulting Donald Trump.
So, this bizarre silence
has gripped --
-Yeah.
-You know, I mean,
it's just not, you know,
a 41-year-old incoming
Republican congressman
from Louisiana died of COVID
before he could take office,
and it was just kind of
like a --
That's a horrific tragedy
for him, for his family,
for this bright life
the guy had ahead of him.
But this --
I think this kind of heavy
blanket of swallowing silence
has been lifted,
and that's a really
important thing.
-It does strike me that --
And, again, we'll see.
And I think that,
you know, sometimes
we talk about tone a lot,
and right now, what we need
is, like, a plan and results.
-Yeah.
-But it does strike me
that President Biden has
historically been pretty good
framing tragedy
and both helping us understand
the way to approach it...
-Yeah.
-...and the way to process it.
And that really struck me
more last night than today.
But, you know, at the memorial
last night, you realized,
"Oh, this is a guy
who understands loss
and understands
moving forward from loss."
-Persistence and endurance.
-Yeah.
-And mourning and keeping going.
Yeah, and I think, in that way,
there's a sort of --
There is a kind of the cosmic
alignment of this guy
that, you know,
I joked today on Twitter
that the first time
he ran for president was 1988,
like "never let go
of your dreams."
[ Both laugh ]
It's an amazing fact,
this guy --
you know, 48 years
in public life.
He's elected as the youngest
you could possibly be
to enter the Senate,
29 years old.
Horrible tragedy.
Lives his entire career --
He's only done one thing
since he was 30...
-Yeah.
-...which is be a public figure
and --
And now, you know, at his age to
take over this country in crisis
having seen what he's seen
and lived through
what he's lived through,
like, there is a certain
kind of weightiness to it all.
And I think you're right.
I think his instincts
on it are right.
Now, the other thing you said
is so true, also.
Like, you know,
competence and getting stuff
done matters more than anything.
I mean, I thought
he hit the right notes today.
There are some extremely,
supremely competent people
that I think highly of
in that administration,
but it's not easy, the task
they have for themselves.
It's not trivial.
-And it's really
important to note,
like, it was never going to be
important -- Oh, sorry --
It was never going to be easy
for any administration.
-No.
-We were never saying
it was easy
for the Trump administration
to deal with this crisis,
but, ultimately, at some point,
you have to have a plan.
I want to talk more with Chris.
We'll be right back
right after this.